-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well.
And now we're gonna
get to the news.
President Biden has reportedly
been telling aides
in private
that he no longer recognizes
the Republican party
and views them
as an existential threat
to democracy.
Oh, good, you're all caught up.
This is like when you watch
three episodes of a show
and you have to wait for
your partner to watch them
before you can move
to Episode 4.
"I hope I can
remember what's going on.
It's been like a year."
President Biden
spoke today in Buffalo
and called on Congress
to pass new gun-control laws.
Also today,
a tree fell in the forest.
In a new interview,
Dr. Anthony Fauci criticized
the Trump administration's
handling of
the coronavirus pandemic and
said it "wasn't optimal,"
which is kind of
like saying
the Hindenburg
experienced a flight delay.
In a new interview,
Supreme Court justice designate
Ketanji Brown Jackson
said the reality show
"Survivor"
is the best show ever.
Well, at least you're prepared
for votes to not go your way.
Sweden announced yesterday
it will apply to join NATO.
Wow! First Finland, now Sweden.
It seems like every day,
we're learning about another
country we could have sworn
was already in NATO.
The CDC this week advised
domestic travelers
to get tested
for the coronavirus
no more than
three days before their trip.
Incidentally,
three days before the trip
is also when your dad thinks
you should get to the airport.
"'Cause there might be traffic!
I'm not crazy.
There's been traffic before."
McDonald's announced yesterday
it would completely exit
the Russian market,
and that's not the only way
they're showing
their support for Ukraine.
[ Audience groans ]
Surprised. I don't know why
that one was the one.
Are you upset that, like --
that Grimace got painted?
Do you guys know
he's supposed to be a taste bud?
I just found out.
It's [bleep] disgusting,
but there you go.
I'm just thrown.
Police in Washington state
over the weekend said
that they had obtained video
of an Arby's manager
urinating into the
restaurant's milkshake machine.
The manager did that?
Come on, man.
You got to learn to delegate.
I don't think there's been
a single piece of good news
in tonight's monologue.
And I know you were bummed out
by Grimace,
but I got some good news.
People are pissing
in the Arby's machines.
According to the latest numbers,
the new 28-step staircase
that opened yesterday
at the Times Square
subway station cost $30 million.
Well, at least they finally
addressed the complaint
that no one had
about the subway.
"I don't mind the delays.
I just wish
the steps were fancier.
I liked the rats.
I just want new steps."
And, finally, it was announced
yesterday that
"The Masked Singer" will return
for an eighth season,
because they need somewhere
to put all the people
too embarrassing for
"Dancing with the Stars."
And that was the monologue,
everybody.